l'annnonce de la décision est un
soulagement pour le gérant du boeuf
blanc et son fils qui n'ont pas
aujourd'hui souhaité s'exprimer à la
sortie du tribunal ils ont été
accueillis par une trentaine de gilet
jaune dijonnais venus les soutenir et
leur exprimer leur gratitude
ces gens là se sont beaucoup dévoué
quand il pour les gilet jaune
ils ont ouvert leur commerce ils ont
pris des risques insensés
d'où la sympathique tous les gilets
jaunes ont pour ces gens là parmi les
personnes présentes une commerçante
dijonnaise elle-même gilet jaune nous a
parlé sous couvert d'anonymat
elle a tenu à rappeler les événements
qui ont précédé les jets de cocktails
molotov contre la préfecture
certes le geste qui qui qui est puni
était certainement condamnable mais il
est en réaction à une une violence qui
avait eu lieu à précédemment dans leur
restaurant
nous sommes le 30 mars 2010neuf acte
vain de gilet jaune au cours de la
manifestation un adolescent a jeté des
oeufs sur les policiers ceux-ci le
poursuivre jusqu'au restaurant le boeuf
blanc dans lequel il pénètre comme le
montrent ces images ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur ensuite n'a pas été filmée
une fois les policiers retirer on
constate les dégâts
une personne à terre victime d'un
malaise dont en état de choc ou
légèrement blessées dont la gérante du
boeuf blanc quelques heures plus tard
son mari et son fils s'en prenait donc
au bâtiment de la préfecture
selon les gilet jaune présent
aujourd'hui au tribunal une quinzaine de
jours d'interruption de travail aurait
été délivré après ces événements et 18
plaintes contre la police ont été
déposées